y quiero hablarles de lo que ocurrió en
mi vida cuando comenzó facebook
abrir una cuenta y empecé a recibir
personas las solicitudes que me hacían
yo las aceptaba
en ese momento no se me ocurría por
ejemplo que la gente podía tener
perfiles falsos
un día empecé a ver que uno de mis
nuevos amigos
like algunas de mis fotos
y lo que me ha llamado la atención de
esos grados pero que no se encontraban
precisamente en la fotografía nuestro yo
me veía desde mi punto de vista más
hermosa sino que a veces estaba sin
maquillaje o estaba un poco excedido de
peso y sin embargo le daba like
así que un día me pregunto es por qué
haría eso y decidí entrar en su perfil
y me di cuenta de que vamos a llamar el
señor t
no tenía muchas publicaciones y pensé
que era un hombre extraño y reservado
pero siendo mujer siendo psicóloga y en
caso de que el horóscopo funciones
siendo sagitariana entonces que desde la
época de no saber los grafos a más con
la gira con las cebras habla con la
cebra así que dije si él no pública
yo voy a saber quién es el al ver a sus
amigos y entré a revisar a sus amigos y
su primera amiga casualmente era una
mujer con discapacidad y aunque bien él
debe ser doctor o debe trabajar en el
área de rehabilitación
pase al segundo amigo y una mujer con
discapacidad
tercer amigo mujer con discapacidad y
así fueron una tras otra
con diversas discapacidades
y cuando ya había llegado como a la
quinta ya sabía que no podía ser médico
ni podía trabajar en el área de
rehabilitación porque de ser así dónde
estaban las fotos de los estetoscopios o
de la rehabilitación o de sus compañeros
de sus colegas porque en todas los que
estaban allí eran mujeres con
discapacidad
y empecé a pasar del asombro al miedo y
recordé a mi esposo que me decía que
tenía que tener cuidado en andar
metiendo locos en mi facebook y luego lo
otro que me empezó a dar fue ira o sea
que en teoría quien se podría para
coleccionar mujeres con discapacidad y
ese mismo día después de que termina de
ver las 59 mujeres que tenía allí y que
tenían discapacidad no escribía algo así
como
la clasificación es un proceso en el
cual uno olvida a la persona y empieza a
escoger por características que la
convierten en cosa cuando buscamos las
personas porque son rubias
porque son altas o porque tienen una
característica particular tú la estás
cosificando así que le dije que yo no le
daba el permiso para que me especificar
a que yo no quería hacer parte de su
colección de su casita del terror
y el al día siguiente me contestó y me
dijo que realmente eso que tenía allí no
hay una colección de terror que todas la
mujeres que estaban allí me parecían
hermosas que todas las mujeres que
estaban allí
eran objeto de su admiración y que
parecía que lo que quería el problema
era yo
luego de muchas conversaciones con el
señor t un día dijo
lo que tú quieres decir es que yo soy un
devoto y yo no tenía ni la menor idea
pero si él estará diciendo eso
obviamente era devoto y dije si eso es
exactamente lo que yo quiero decir y
cuando terminamos de hablar yo fui a
papá google y coloque de loto y aparecía
de la virgen del carmen del salto niño
de la cuchilla y de otros santos
y yo dije esto no es lo que me está
diciendo entonces dado que habíamos
estado conversando sobre la discapacidad
con lo que
devoto y con lo que discapacidad
y coloque en mi facebook donde había
muchos psicólogos donde había
psiquiatras donde había estudiantes de
psicología escribí alguien sabe de una
parafilia que se llame devoto y
empezaron a bromear y me dijeron debe
ser alguien que es fanático religioso y
que a lo mejor le gusta hacer el amor en
contextos que tienen que ver con la
iglesia y me di cuenta de que nadie
sabía acerca de eso y entonces después
de haber estado asustada decidí que yo
iba a investigar sobre eso y de los
resultados de esta investigación y de
sus implicaciones de lo que vengo a
hablar hoy
por favor
un debate es una persona cuya partida se
caracteriza porque experimenta placer y
porqué erotiza a una persona con
discapacidad por favor la siguiente la
palabra parafina está
formada por dos términos silvia que
significa deseo amor atracción y para
qué significa extraño anormal o
patológico de manera tal que para filia
sería algo así como un deseo raro o un
amor patológico
los devotos son personas a los que les
interesa a los que lo es pero quizá la
discapacidad cualquier tipo de
discapacidad pero el tipo de debod estoy
yo estudio son los devotos están
interesados en personas como yo con
discapacidad motriz así que esos de
botín se dividen en dos categorías los
vacíos fílmicos que son aquellos a los
que me interesan personas como yo que
usan aparatos que usan muletas que usan
sillas de ruedas y lo sacro tomo cínicos
a quienes les interesa las chicas
amputadas desafortunadamente para mí lo
sacro tomo físicos son mayoría
esta investigación o la investigación
que lleve a cabo a lo largo de 10 años
me permitió entrevistar a 2.234 de botes
de cinco continentes
los entrevistó de manera personal a
algunos de ellos
y a otros a través de internet con
entrevistas en español y en inglés
los resultados muy a groso modo fueron
los siguientes un número mayoritario de
las personas que son devotos tienen
edades que están entre los 31 y los 40
años porque yo hipotetizó o sea mi
hipótesis es que después de los 40 años
algunas personas empiezan a tener temor
de acceder a la tecnología tienen miedo
a la tecnología y como la factura mayor
parte de la muestra la octubre a través
de internet por eso después de cuarenta
el número empieza a descender porque es
menos de 30 porque la construcción de la
personalidad es definir quién eres tú se
va haciendo sobre todo cuando tienes
cierta madurez y eso ocurre alrededor de
los 30 años la mayor parte de ellos eran
masculinos de sexo masculino tanto que
la proporción es aproximadamente de una
mujer cada 250 hombres
y ellos son de nivel socioeconómico
medio y creo que eso es lo que
facilitaba que tuvieran acceso a la
tecnología
ha surgido varias hipótesis acerca de
qué es lo que hace que una persona sea
el botín
y casi todos ellos he encontrado que hay
una
ha habido una experiencia con la
discapacidad bien sea de manera directa
porque han tenido discapacidad o de
manera indirecta porque han tenido algún
familiar o algún vecino con discapacidad
sin embargo no todo el mundo que ha
tenido experiencia con discapacidad se
convierte en devota y entonces
seguramente al igual que cualquier
fenómeno psicológico es de naturaleza
multicausal e incluye componentes
biológicos psicológicos y sociales lo
que sí ha encontrado esto con mucha
frecuencia provienen de familias rígidas
frías o sobre protectoras que algunos de
ellos tienen baja autoestima y que
parecen tener necesidad de control
si eso es lo que he logrado como
resultado de la investigación y muchos
más pero que no me va a dar chance de
decir laura qué temas quedan pendientes
por explorar quedan pendiente por
explorar porque algunas discapacidades
son preferidas con respecto a otro es
decir porque hay mayor cantidad de
devotos que les interesa a los que nos
interesa la discapacidad motriz
con relación por ejemplo a la evidencia
otro elemento importante es
porque se da esa desproporción entre
mujeres de botín y hombres de botín
adicionalmente a eso hay diferencia en
el perfil psicológico entre los hombres
de botín y las mujeres de botín
y por último sí
y comentaba antes que parece haber un
elemento importante con relación a una
experiencia con la discapacidad
significa eso que en aquellos países
donde ha existido guerras o donde ha
existido catástrofes y como resultado de
ello han quedado muchas mujeres con
discapacidad en esos países así hay
mayor cantidad de votos
adelante por favor
venezuela actualización necesaria porque
un tema tan rebuscado podría ser
importante desde el punto de vista
social y que tiene que ver con la
actualización
yo creo que esto tiene que ver con
varios elementos el primero de ellos la
actualización está en el hecho de que se
está haciendo una investigación novedosa
con un gran número de sujetos y esto del
número de sujetos por haber tenido la
muestra de 2.234 sujetos te permite
generalizar más fácilmente los
resultados conseguidos en esa muestra a
toda la población de botín pero
adicionalmente yo creo que
y lo más importante de esta
investigación es que ha permitido me ha
permitido y ha permitido a aquellos que
están vinculados a la investigación
replantearse conceptos como discapacidad
normalidad y belleza
porque cuando se habla del tema debut y
nos escandalizamos tanto porque
percibimos que el de botti es un
depredador sexual porque pensamos que el
de gotti es alguien que tiene una
patología psicológica los pocos las
pocas investigaciones hay hasta el
momento en que lo vi solamente son
investigaciones 3 de naturaleza grupal y
3 de estudio de casos y en todos ellos
se abordaba el tema de la patología pero
porque nos parece patológico el de gotti
y con lo que parece una frase de don de
bot y dice si estas comunas prefería que
sea una mujer con discapacidad si estas
comunas de algún salto porque las
puertas no pero si tú quieres estar con
una entonces te conviertes en un
pervertido
y probablemente lo que hace que veamos
al devoto como patológico es lo
siguiente es una forma en que nosotros
entendemos la discapacidad entendemos la
discapacidad oa una persona con
discapacidad como una persona que no es
productiva o que puede ser una carga
para el estado a la que tienes que darle
una subvención una persona que no es
hermosa o una persona que tiene esa
condición como resultado de algún
castigo divino entonces si una
discapacidad te hace eso te hace una
persona disminuida cualquiera que pueda
desear y erotizar a una persona con
discapacidad definitivamente tiene que
estar mal y esto y esto es algo
importante
y esto es algo importante por lo
siguiente yo no sé si ustedes se han
enterado que si vive lo suficiente todos
ustedes se van a convertir en una
persona con discapacidad porque en la
medida que vaya pasando el tiempo la
agudeza visual y auditiva va
disminuyendo vamos sintiendo dolores y
entonces si se viven los suficientes
ustedes también van a tener una
discapacidad pero como el tema de la
discapacidad y la sexualidad solemos
pensar que las personas con discapacidad
son asexuales y porque pensamos que son
asexuales porque generalmente la forma
en que comunicamos los deseos
sexuales obviamente es a través de
nuestros movimientos porque te damos con
nuestros movimientos manejamos la cadera
o caminamos de una manera particular
para manifestar que tenemos deseo sexual
pero en una persona con discapacidad
el movimiento está alterado y entonces
no puede comunicar de manera suficiente
ese deseo sexual eso se ve alterado
lo otro es que pensamos que una persona
con discapacidad además de que no tiene
deseo sexual es como un niño un niño
dependiente alguien que necesita que lo
ayude y que por lo tanto lo tutela
si es así si la mujer es como un niño y
si la mujer la mujer con discapacidad
obviamente si la mujer con discapacidad
es un niño y además no tiene deseo
sexual entonces un debut y sería algo
equivalente a un pedófilo
esta lógica se siguió con ponen esto fue
la primera mujer con discapacidad que
apareció en una portada de playboy
lo que hicieron fue retocar sus piernas
para que se vieran normales y no se
vieran como las mías que son más
delgadas o más flácida y quitaron de las
fotografías las silla de ruedas y cuando
le preguntaron jefe no era porque había
tomado la decisión de presentar a estos
visualmente como una mujer normal
obviamente normal en los términos de
playboy un libro que de esta manera
impedía que playboy caminara por un
camino de cosas pervertidas y
explotadoras en los cuales se vinculaba
la sexualidad con las personas con
discapacidad entonces la primera
actualización es preguntarnos si
realmente que exista un devoto está
vinculado a un deseo pervertido o es que
somos prejuicios o con relación a la
discapacidad y eso nos hace ver como
enfermos a aquellos que puedan erotizar
a una mujer con discapacidad
lo otro que quisiera que nos
preguntáramos pues
qué es normal este hoja normal porque
consideramos que los devotos son
anormales y después los criterios son
anormales
resulta que investigando me he dado
cuenta de que el concepto de normalidad
puede ser visto es nítido desde
distintas ópticas desde el punto de
vista legal lo normal es lo que no es
delito desde el punto de vista
estadístico lo normal es lo frecuente lo
común desde el punto de vista
filogenético lo normal es lo que hace la
especie humana pero que también hacen
los animales
desde el punto de vista psicológico lo
normal es lo que no causa daño y desde
el punto de vista moral lo normal es lo
que es bueno
entonces
por favor
de ser así que es lo normal o desde este
criterio estamos hablando de normalidad
esa es la gran pregunta lo otro sobre lo
que quiero hablar es sobre el tema de la
belleza
nosotros tenemos el concepto del griego
de la belleza
y según ese ideal obviamente las mujeres
con discapacidad no son hermosas pero
existen otros ideales de belleza
uno de esos ideales de bellezas
alternativos son unidades japonés vamos
a utilizar la palabra espero
pronunciarla bien se llama wabi sabi
wabi sabio es el equivalente al ideal de
belleza griego pero en japón para que
algo sea bello desde esta óptica debe
cumplir tres características
nada dura nada está completo y nada está
perfecto entonces creo que en este
momento yo me siento mucho más cómoda
con el concepto de belleza japonés que
no me exige simetría y no me exige
perfección que con el ideal de belleza
griego
por último
y esto es lo que quisiera dejarles para
la reflexión si podemos cuestionar el
concepto de belleza en venezuela que es
el país de las mujeres bellas si podemos
construir enriquecer ese concepto de
belleza entonces en este país podemos
lograr cualquier cosa eso es lo que
tenía que decirles muchas gracias
[Aplausos]